こんにちははじめ殺王ですいよいよ夏ですね皆さん赤甲羅は好きですか僕は大好きです
というわけで夏位のコカコーラおいしいんですけどもみなさん物感じるときがある
でしょ
モグ時の状況とかその時のコンディションによって味って結構変わると思うんですよと
いう意味でせっかく夏になって暑い季節になってきたので今回は
夏の交付がうまい週間さあレンジということで夏といえばいろんなシチュエーションが
想像されるのってこのタイミングにコカコーラー飲めば美味しいなっていう場面なんか
ご用意したのでどの増強でここ4ラウンド目ば一番美味しいのがちょっと継承していき
たいと思いますかなり僕の主観が入っていると思いますすいません皆さんはどう思うか
わかりませんが僕がこの状況でどんなら美味しい
だろうなという場面をちょっといろいろ想像して飲んでいきたいと思いますでないぞ
[音楽]
これ
ん
んん
持ってません
この夏の小太刀食べたいというの限界のどのかながらを越えた先で連絡
諸富たいますうーん
ん
[音楽]
えっ
ん
[音楽]
飲みたいプープーンっ
ん
ねぇ
もうちょいやーん
ん
うーんん
[音楽]
た限界はデポでつ食べてたんで口がもう
仕様なんですね彼方の増大で水分を求めているんだかに摂取するこのコーラー非常に
美味しいでカナダがほ吸ってる
凝らを
美味しい
[音楽]
はい続いてはこちら暗示ジャンプでございます動画よく飛んでる印象あると思うんです
けどめちゃ曲苦手なんでしょ高いところで今もう卒業の何しゃべり
米がわかんないぐらいの歓迎されやってるんでこの恐怖心に打つ買った後の今度第二の
効果コーラー
絶対美味しいと思うんで早速やっていきたいと
思います入っています雨降ってるとの見方に影響とかあるんですけど
どうでしょうね
ああああああ
こえーあー
ダダダーって本当にヤバいん
温度にヤバイいてきまーす
両足を
ちょっとはいこれあの落ちるまでちょっと時間があるんですよねだから俺はいつ訪れる
かわからないって恭子なんか心を形で持ちながら今
マスタートンデモなことになっております
さあ来ましたまだですよいつ訪れるかわからないも僕コカコーラを抱きしめての哺乳
普通の人間はこれ両手でも積んでその恐怖心
は普通の人料理絶対もあるんですよねなぜなら片手に校歌コーラを持っている
未だ今通ってる戦頑張っています静雄に声です5を連れか分からない
ただ僕は種だバッジバックパッます fudge まーすっ
watchman 分
うわあ気持ち
ここまで来ただけ理由
じゃないかー
なんで番ティのすぎな所ってさぁお礼までが本当に怖いんですけど
モリタート3つ気持ちいいですよねなのでここでののコカコーラが美味しいなと思い
ます本当になきゃさっきまで姉売ってたからマイナス栄養マリンと visit the
以降のコンディションで心はせていただきます
いいねぇでは最高の子ご覧いただきます
[音楽]
[拍手]
これはなかった画像会に来る噂だぞ
[音楽]
ん
tan
ni
[音楽]
経済ので
rar
[拍手]
はっはっは
wh
1アッパ
uh
バッハ
none コカコーラの坊主
[音楽]
がんばーい
me
[音楽]
ん
はい柱列水やさあ2でございます猿の入った後
整っている状態があるんですけどももうなんか色々研ぎ澄まされて感覚が
さあ試しっていう言葉が悪くないさあが入ったとっていろんなものを食べたり飲んだり
するとおいしいらしいのでバッチバチに今日はさあで決まってから悪口がコーラ飲んで
みたいと思います
ん
goo
me
結構汗がきましたね目 lovers と思い
ん
あああああん
うううう
par
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
あっはっは10分くらい中華しましたね結構いい感じに来ていると思いますもう
よしめっちゃ汗かいたと思うんで行っていきましょうか
それ書はすべて星
僕のコツなんですけど首をちょっとだけ左に傾けるとすげー
きます
[音楽]
マウスってあ
tee
いただきます
[音楽]
うわぁ
整った彼がコカコーラを飲んだ瞬間
光が世界を包み込んなのであった
[音楽]
次は番犬と boa なぁ
rar
いろんな上級税凝ら飲んできたんですけども結局
スポーツの後になものが一番おいしいですよはいかこれ
しまうシートもんで古賀バケット物店海まで行ってから5分
僕コーラを味わいたいと思います皆さんもよろしくねくださいああ
[拍手]
はーい
はぁ
[拍手]
ん
ran
dee dee
can you do her
ni ん
ああああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
を使えそうですはじめさんコカコーラーですありがとう
この時のこれはってた
40分なね4校ターブ1試合ノーストップじゃいました
いただきますイェイ
いただきます
[音楽]
言葉にできないくらいよ
をしたですなんかコカコーラが美味しいのはもちろんなんですけど体が水分を欲して
いるんですねほんとに欲しい奴のほしいですね
心美味しいですよだ
ああああああ
スポーツが終わった後にみんなで飲むコカコーラも格別に美味しいせ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ああ
[音楽]
グラバー1たーーー
かまれが窓へ
ええええええ
突っ張ってくださいねやばいなぁわー
ご愛用
うわーやっぱまずデバイスことや倍にすればですねやばい
できます
本当に濃いんですけどおいしいコカコーラを飲むためいきます
西1通1
ん
r ん
じゃない
1子供声が出ません本当に強い人は大江おいてください
ん
だよなん
ああああああ
まずで喉カラカラ本当にこれじゃ皆さん
知識
価格はですね
なんか& kern 回りつでもの座長からたらなけどはしたいと思います
になります
うふんええええ出会えフェスは
いやーなかなかのレベルですよこの美味しさは
[音楽]
生きてて良かった
一番ん
注意呼び出されたから来たんでいるどうしたんでこんな報告2
一君
俺
いい
ありがとう
[音楽]
あれ
立花
ええええええ
ああああああ
達まぁ
全編英語で木崎が住んだよなあああああああ
唾でもって
元が好きだったらいいんだけどなぁ
ん
立花からもらったコカコーラわー
なぜか
ana つったかった
はいという意味でいかがだったでしょうか僕がこれまでの前世で軽減したことないよう
な場面でも各コーラーていろいろ飲んでみたわけなんですけども
もうどういうおいしかったですもすべての場面がおいしかったですけどなんか色々味の
知恵があったんですけども
今回のチャレンジで私が一番おいしいと思った瞬間は本当はヤラセなしですもう心から
品
てほしかったなと思った瞬間は
すー
サウナでした800でしたーー
他がも美味しかったですよもう大人だねのめちゃくちゃ美味しかったんですけども水に
味だけで測ると最後の後にホンダコカコーラが一番美味しかったです
もう優勝でございましたん見方ですよね本当に
アイテムで今回ですね向草間チャレンジ僕はこういうチャレンジさせていただいたん
ですけども僕以外にもいろんな方が後期サーバーチャレンジに参加しています
ちゃんとですね23残った松レンズにチャレンジしていますのでそちらのチャレンジ
どうぞぜひご覧下さい詳しくは動画概要欄からチェックしてみてください
俺も見よというわけで暑い季節になってきたので皆さんおいしくコカコーラ飲み
ましょう
じゃあ
んだなぁ
んが
まんだ
ん
鼻をかんだ